mixing colors is second nature for young
Sulaiman abdur-rahman but after painting
for years it was only when Sudan's
Revolution began in December that he
started feeling like a real artist and
that every stroke of the brush now gives
him the chance to show his talent as
well as feel like a part of the
revolution by spreading its messages
[Music]
people have become close to art since
the Revolution and they've started
paying more attention to it so this is
to show the Sudanese art to bring it out
Sudan's visual art has been oppressed
people from the field were not knowing
there was a clamp down on art for 30
years now we want to bring that out
since anti-government protests started
last December over the rising costs of
bread and fuel artwork has appeared on
walls in Sudan's capital many told then
President Omar al-bashir his time was up
and so it was his 30-year rule brought
to an end by the military after a
long-running sitting where every wall
was covered with colors that reflected
the demands of the protesters and their
hopes for Sudan's future art has become
a symbol of defiance for many Sudanese
here in Khartoum these walls were
painted by pro-democracy protesters in
April but whitewash by the military
following the killing of dozens of
protesters two months later within a few
weeks new paintings appeared and that's
not the only form of art that's thriving
poems and music was strictly regulated
during the shears rule with anyone
deemed to write anything viewed even as
remotely critical to the government
harassed or arrested now poets and
musicians say they feel no fear
poetry played a big role in the
revolution most of the slogans chanted
during protests came from poets who
wrote to fuel the revolution and
motivate the protesters it empowered
people and continues to the songs that I
used to sing at parties were turned down
by radio stations and there were other
artists who faced the same thing I'm
happy that such a day has come where we
can express our ideas through our music
not like the past where it had to be
careful about what I write in the song
the revolution was spearheaded by the
Sudanese professionals Association which
includes artists some of their work was
destroyed during the political turmoil
but they say the new work should be
preserved for future generations that
people will carry the messages of those
drawings and other arts for what we wish
is that these arts are now preserved for
future generations so that they know
about the history and the role these
arts have played in the Revolution and
the lives sacrificed for it to succeed
so dance revolution provided space for
Suleiman and many other artists to
unleash their creativity giving him
freedom which he says he'll guard with
every color he paints Heba Morgan al
Jazeera Khartoum